*whispering*
This...video was brought to you by Lootcrate
*Inspirational music*
*Pewds mating call*
Doesn't work does it? I'll tell you what does work.
Inflatables.
Today's video is all about inflatables. Whats inflatable, Brad?
*Laughter*
My ego is so inflated, that I need to fill it with other items,
and that's what we're doing here today on the poodiepie channel.
Let's go!
Guess what the first item is. (is it TITS?)
That's right, you guessed it!
Pteranodon..?
Inflatable
Camerman: Say that again, what is that, sorry?
(oh)
Its a pteradonon (pteranodon)
pterran
p
ptera
pteran
pteraanodon
ptera
pteranodon
Aw, man, this gonna take me so much effort to blow this up (oh really, Pewds? ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) )
*sigh* The things I do for you,  bros...
*gasp*
I'm exhausted
Oh
P'aw man
So much effort!
Fucking hell!
Fuckin' in hell!
Ayyyyy *laughs*
Collect them all
Go pteranodon! (flies away majestically as pews throws it)
(Flight of the Valkyries plays)
Woah!
Woah dude
That was f**king awsome
He's a good pteranodon
I thought they were called pterodactyls
He knows
He'll-
He'll put me under his wing any day
pokemonodon: "That's right!"
Is that a good voice?
(dinosaur noises)
*laughs*
The fu*k did you say about my mother?
Shut the fu*k up!!
I will destroy you!
*dramatic music*
IT'S STILL ALIVE!!
WHY WON'T YOU DIE?!
*sad piano music*
shhhhh
*gasping*
SHHH
shhh shh shhhh
:'(
I don't know what it is
We'll fill it up with my ego
and see what comes out
Is this a furry costume?
You got me a fu*king furry costume?
Who do you think I am? Pyrocynical?
Oh my god, that's awesome!
*laughs*
This is how I got Marzia ;)
This is-
This is how I got mar..zia
I thought that lost like half the air
Okay, here we go
here we go
why?
i just realize, why?
*laugh of shame :v* I buy this
oh it's for kids
yeah
nono..that was pretty shit
the next item
is
oh it's hilarious
that's
that's funny
it's a walking frame
*audience laughter*
whooooaaaa
dawg
yo, dawg
this is cool man
alright, let's blow this shit up
just like your mother does
yeah that's right
alright it's done
now let's see
if this thing works
*huge sucess!!!*
i've fallen!!!
IM DYING!!
HAHAHAHA HEU HAHAH
HELP ME EDGAR
HEEELP
help me
EDGAR!!
YOU SON OF A BI**H!!!
What is the one thing that we all want?    (Bewbs, obviously)
That's right
Boobs
Inflatable boobs
Let's give it a go
*gasps*
One titty!
This is the kind of video that if my child-
my child will see
*laughs*
If I walk in, my kid is watching this video
NOOO!!!
Hi guys, welcome to Sssniperwolf's channel
You got roasted!
*explosion*
*breathing heavily*
*muffled scream*
*screaming continues*
The next item is for, uh, cats
I don't have a cat
But I have Edgar
EDGAR!
You're gonna- hey, you're gonna look adorable, alright?
Just trust me, alright?
*laughs*
*lil' fart noise*
Ooooh my god, yes!
*gasps*
*laughs*
YOU'RE SO CUTE!
OH MY GOD!
Edgar: No, don't look at me
Don't look at me
DON'TTTT
This is how I kiss dogs
*fails to deep-throat Edgar, chokes on his massive head schlong*
*gags loudly*
Okay, so the next item is...
Party boy, inflatable party boy
I probably bought five of these in my lifetime
which is five more than you should ever buy
I mean, love- that's love at first sight right there
Look at those orangey lips
and blue eyes
I'm not even going to blow this up
cause he's gonna use too much of my ego
I kinda like him just as a skin suit
You know? (no we don't Pewds)
Is it-should I...kiss him?
*awkward silence*
*Romantic Kissing music*
So, so how are you guys doing?
T-t-tell...how are you guys
*eagle screeches*
What's dat?
SPONSOR EAGLE
*sponsor eagle intro*
Sponsor eagle is here!
AHH THANK YOU
*blows kiss*
Alright, lets op-
OOOOOOHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
We gotta lil bit o' that
Oh, you know what that means ladies
A little foreplay
And Loot Crate, I love you- you're the best
Like, think about
We work with a lot of different brands...
Loot Crates are the only one that let us do what we want
*chuckles*
Check our lootcrate.com/pewds
Enter the code 'Pewds'
OHHHHHHH
OH
I'm opening last month's theme which is dystopian
The theme changes every month, the 19th
So you gotta order before then if you want the theme
Next month's theme...is futuristic
The only way to find out about the future is to order in the present
*brief holy music*
Oh, it's exci-  it's a good package
*rattles box frantically, Pewds begins to seizure*
OOHhhhh ahhhh
Oh, god damn it was so neatly packed
A T-shirt
Ho-ly shit, this is a cool one
I like this one
It's Robocop with like a Japanese style
No it's not uh that was racist
I mean why's there a sun behind it?
Is it?
Really fucking cool, I like it
That's really cool
UUhhh we have a Matrix puzzle
because the Matrix is a puzzling series of movies- trilogy
It has three hundred puzzle pieces
You have to be 17 plus to su- WHYY?
What the fuck is in this puzzle?
I have never seen that before
I wanna fucking do this puzzle now
What is in this puzz-le
That's a brilliant thing
I wanted to see Trinity's titties since I was 13
Literally, Michael is terrified of me touching this item...
because he thinks the box is cool and he doesn't want me to ruin it so...
*inhales sharply*
Uh this is really cool
Fallout vinyl collectable
*Pewds clatters box*
You get scared Michael?
Don't worry nothing bad is gonna happen
Oh Brad has it, it's gone
Michael: Are you happy?
So the next item....
GRAAHHAHAHHHAH
*laughs*
Did I scare you? I scared bra-AHAHAH
wha-what are these? I don't know what it is
Someone in the background: its for a cake- you bake a cake
No I don't think it's for cakes
You wanna b- you wanna make a terminator cake?
That's ?"terrifly"????
Ooooo I love this, I love this pin
I am a big fan of pins
This is a cool pin
We have Bioshock Infinite- I love that game
I am so excited- what could this be?
A key blank...OH wait
That was the key! Where's the key?
OHHHHHHH
Oh, it's like in the game!
Oh that's cool
If you play the game and know the reference you'd be like ohuhhuhh
That's the- that's the Loot Crate value, you know?
So its got the bird or the cage- is it the bird or the cage?
*kiss* Loot Crate I love you
Thank you for supplying me with awesome items every month
Guys, if you haven't checked out Loot Crate yet, I recommend that you do so...
Not only because it supports the show but I really appreciate it
Thank you so much
Check out Loot Crate- go to lootcrate.com/pewds
Enter the code "pewds", you guys know the drill
Sponsor Eagle will hook you guys up
*music*
Hurry up with item
It's a spa- it's a portable spa
Everyone, it's a spa. It is a spa.
I bought this with real money
*Sigh* I need to relax
*Breathing*
You're so tense Felix
Background person: You're so tense Felix
*Laughs*
Thank you Brad, you know I'm a hard worker
Say I'm a hard worker
Background guy: You're a really hard worker a-
I know yeah I-I work overtime a lot
Background guy: hey, why not try- why not have a spa
Tell them- tell them how humble I am
and how much I donate to charity.
You're so humble!
I am!
Brad: I can't believe you don't have an ego
I'm not here to talk about my charity work..
or all the time I spend helping out other people
and just been an overall good person..
But.. You know what? I think  I've earned a day off!
So let's blow up the spa!
if you get enough subs you can live the high life!
That actually feels really nice!
I've earned this!
Oh I work so hard!
The real YouTuber Life!
It got in my fucking eye!
What you doing?
It's a spa! I need to be like..
I don't like this! Stop!
Hey! Stop!
You're ruining the champigne! Ahh
Ok, do it again, Brad?
*peace*
No! NO!!
No! It's sinking!
Who did this?
Who did this??
You son of a bitch!
No! No!
Don't film this! Help!
No!
I'll get you for this Pterodactyl!
I'll get you for this!